[inaudible] joining me today is the host
of pseudo intellectual on blaze TV and
the artist formerly known as
roaming millennial. Lauren. Chad,
welcome to the Rubin report.
Thank you so much for having me.
I am so stoked to be here in person to
see things in real life. It's unreal.
This is very bizarre because somehow
we have never met in person before and
people freak when they see you tubers
on the street and now we're to youtube
people meeting for the first.
I know. I, I feel really weird seeing you
in three dimensions. It's just unnatural.
I feel like I need some sort
of glass between us. Yeah,
bring me back to my comfort
zone, but it's, it's great.
I,
I poked you in the shoulder before just
to make sure you're real because people
always want to touch me to be, if
I'm real and we are real. Okay.
There's a ton I want to talk to you about.
Technically.
You have done the Rubin report one time.
Yeah,
a little less than three years ago.
We did a youtube week where I was just
sort of reaching out to interesting
youtubers that I thought were
doing something kind of cool.
And you had a small channel I think
you probably had like, no, no,
maybe you figured out for
me like certainly thousand.
Yeah, I remember definitely before I had
passed 100,000. So it was the early days.
I remember I was so
nervous about that call.
I had to like put my
dog in the other room.
I was in my living room on my like
dinky little laptop and it was, I mean,
anytime,
I hope you realize you help
small youtubers so much
when you do those types of
videos because it makes a huge
difference in our following.
Yeah. Cool. Well I'm glad to do it and
many people helped me before that. So, uh,
so I had you on and you were sort of just,
when we went through the list basically
of who we are going to put on, uh,
your name came up a couple of times.
People had recommended you and I
watched some of your videos. I thought,
here is this young woman who's actually
making sense saying some politically
incorrect things and, uh,
actually doing something good.
So how did that happen? What got
you into this crazy world? Thank
you. I appreciate that. Yeah. Um,
and I think I started off the way a lot
of youtubers nowadays are starting off
kind of just as a hobby,
something to do for fun because for
all that we rag on social media,
I think it has kind of created this
atmosphere where people feel like their
opinion matters and they want to chip
in and they want to contribute even if
they're not getting a lot of
recognition for it or money for.
So it was really just a way for me to feel
like I was participating in, you know,
the crazy amount of discourse
we were having. And so this was,
it'll be three years ago
in May that I started, um,
my first few videos for awhile actually,
we're just like those slideshow
presentations. My face wasn't in it. Um,
and my first ever video I think
was about transgenderism. Uh,
the whole idea of like transgender
versus transgender, you know,
the idea of many genders I think.
Um,
and for awhile I kind of put out a
video or two or a month just for fun.
And then eventually I started
getting more and more subscribers.
And after it wasn't even that long,
maybe eight or so months I was able to
make youtube my fulltime job through
things like crowd funding. And it was, uh,
it's been a pretty crazy ride ever since.
And you've watched,
you mature and I'm watching your ideas
sort of come together as totally been a
joy to watch. Truly.
Yeah. Um, so you went,
so first your name was roaming millennial.
Did you just feel that you needed to
have a moniker and not go by real name to
the biggest introvert
you could ever imagine?
Like I'm the person in class who
never really spoke up and less a,
the teacher specifically
called on me or you know,
attendance was part of the grade cause
I wanted to get the good grade. Um,
so I wanted to contribute,
but I think for a lot of
people who are maybe more shy,
not to mention the amount that certain
opinions get demonized nowadays. Uh,
you know, I felt like kind of being
anonymous at first it was safer.
I was less embarrassing. People wouldn't
really like attribute stuff to me.
I wasn't necessarily worried about
blowback specifically until like I got a
little bit bigger and then I was like, oh,
maybe it is a good thing that, you know,
my real name isn't attached to it. But um,
you know, roaming millennial come from,
I just totally made it up.
It was just like,
cause I've moved a lot and I was doing
some like HR research at the time from my
main job.
And so I was very entrenched in the
whole like generational separations.
Um, you know, millennials versus like
baby boomers, Gen Xers, whatever.
So had I known, I would end up
going by that for like two years.
I maybe would have put a little
bit more thought into it, but yeah,
people still call me roaming and
I'm fine with that. You know,
you can call me Romy or whatever.
I don't mind.
Definitely not the worst thing I'm being
called right now. Thank God. Listen,
I'm making this up, but I don't think I
am. I don't think I even knew your name.
Was Lauren until way
after I interviewed you.
I called you roaming and you just went
by roaming and I was like, all right,
look all around.
You know what's funny?
I feel like people who spend a lot of
time online or kind of social media
circles, that doesn't really
bother us. Cause I, I don't know.
You've had Rocka Rocka Alia on your show
and you know, I'm a fan of his love,
his stuff.
He's funny and a really smart guy.
I think people who may be just know
him for his music don't realize.
But then I realized the other day
like, wait, what is his real name?
I just call him Rocca. Well,
I truly do this very moment.
I cannot remember what his
first name that I'm fine with.
[inaudible] I don't feel like I know
him less as a content creator because of
that. But, uh, you know, I started doing
more like in person events and kind of,
you know, I was on Fox News and stuff
and that's when I was kind of like,
for people who aren't
in the youtube sphere,
it is kind of weird to just
go buy a moniker. Yeah.
So were you always interested in politics?
Did that, was it always saying that?
I mean you're, you're a fellow political
science graduate and political.
Yeah. So yeah, there's three
people that are doing it, right.
Shapiro was also political science,
Matt Christiansen as well.
So there's four of us that actually our
degree in your face. Everybody. Yeah.
I'm using my poly psy degree.
Uh, yeah, I've always been
interested in it. Um, I'm,
I'm not exactly sure what it is,
but I'm just interested in,
I guess the way society functions and I
think it may be stems from a desire to
want to improve things. And
uh, I feel like, you know,
every,
every job,
every profession out there is valid
and is making our lives better.
I just happened to be
interested in, you know, kind
of systems, governments, family,
stuff like that.
Yeah.
So tell me a little bit more about just
growing up before you were a youtuber
and somewhat public person.
You are half Asian.
I'd been treating you as a full white
person here. I hope that's okay.
You know, I have been noticing
that there's been some
microaggressions. Yeah. Yes.
Tell me all about your Asian privilege.
I am half Chinese. My father is from
Hong Kong. I was born in Canada,
but I,
when I was only a few months old,
moved to Hong Kong and that's really
where I grew up. Aside from that,
I've also lived in, uh,
Shanghai, Singapore in London,
and then I came to the
states for university.
So I've had a pretty like Kametra
politan mixed background. Um,
in addition to my like,
racial heritage.
And I think coming on to an American
campus for the first time was the first
time I was really made aware
of my race in a very real way.
Because growing up,
you're Asian in like Asian expat
circles is actually not that uncommon.
I'm not gonna say that
there's a lot of us,
but you don't have like quite a few mixed
kids in the schools that I was going
to like the American,
like kind of foreign ex schools.
So I never really thought about it.
I had friends of all different races
growing up and we got along fine. I mean,
I'm not gonna say that I was colorblind
because I knew like, oh yeah,
this person's Indian,
this person's white. Uh,
but it was never a point of
contention or anything like that. But,
you know, going on to an American college
campus, it was a whole different story.
And I think
that's maybe that, like when you
first noticed that difference,
it was a little bit strange because I
remember I was really excited to go to,
I'd never lived in America before.
I had been going to American
schools all my life. And you know,
I had so many friends that were American,
but I never lived in America before.
And I was really excited about it,
uh,
because in schools I learned
American history and stuff like that,
but never lived there.
So when I started college,
I was really excited to get the American
experience because it was almost like a,
you know,
it was the,
the place that movies took place in
when we're celebrities were from where
everything I read about in books happen.
So I,
I really like built it up in my head and
I was excited to get that experience.
But it's funny when I got there
and I saw my dorm room assignment,
um, USC, which is where I did my freshman
year, they have this thing where they,
they kind of segregate dorms a little
bit. Um, there's like a gay floor,
there is a black floor, there's
like a Muslim housing thing. Um,
and I went to look at my room assignments
and every single other person that was
in my dorm also had an Asian last name.
So I was in essentially the Asian ghetto.
Wow.
So that was kind of like the first
time where I was like, wait, what?
Because I had never,
I'd never really experienced
being stereotyped in such
an obvious way for that.
And maybe it maybe was just an accident,
but I all I know is that I never
volunteered. Like, Hey, Yep,
put me with all the other agents.
Um, I actually was an accident can,
right, right. Yeah. There's not
that many Asians at USC. Uh,
that it just like literally every
other person in that suite, uh,
there's like a thing, maybe
like 15 other people. Um,
so I applied for a room transfer because I
was like, well, I mean, no offense, like,
I'm sure you're lovely people,
but I,
I didn't come here to just live among
other agents. I want a, you know,
just a general mixed American,
whatever experience. Um,
and so that was like the first instance.
And then, you know, uh, aside from that,
I had, I was approached a lot by
people to join, like, you know,
the Asians in film club or
the Asians in this club.
And that's when I started to
notice that race was a lot,
a much bigger deal in America than it
was for me growing up in Hong Kong or
Canada.
So, I know you talk about
identity politics a lot now,
but what were your politics like before
you realize that this whole thing was
happening?
Well, I mean, I was conservative
going into college. I went to college,
Republican you, sorry, I college
republicans meetings when I was 17,
so I didn't have really a moment where
I was liberal then became conservative.
But I, in terms of the race
issue, if it's even an issue,
I just wasn't thinking about it. Right.
I was just for like, you know, uh,
economic responsibility, lower the
budget, et Cetera, et cetera. Um,
I, I think it kind of,
it made me feel in a way,
I don't want to sound like an SJW,
but marginalize the way that they were
constantly bringing up my, my Asianess.
And I think that's what
made me more interested in
cultural issues as opposed to
just governmental issues
because I was seeing how,
how much of their philosophy was affecting
me in my everyday life. And I mean,
I have people who, you know,
on my channel, they say,
you're always talking about
culture and social stuff.
Why don't you talk about more policy.
And I mean, frankly my viewership,
I think it's 75% under the age of 35 and
for a lot of these college students or
people who have just graduated,
this is stuff that affects them
every day of their life. Like they,
they are bombarded in like social media,
pop culture with your races this versus
uh, you know, your race did this,
you can't talk about this because
of your race. So for these people,
and for me at the time, that was the
biggest thing that was affecting us.
When you started doing the videos
then were you like, holy cow,
there is a world of people talking
about this? Because I mean that's,
even though I did come from the left,
so I wasn't always let's say on this side,
whatever that means. Like when I
started talking about these things,
I suddenly was like, Oh, I'm not the
only one. There are that many yet.
And now they're kind of growing.
But yeah,
pretty nice feeling to know
some other people out there.
It was, and actually, you know, I
grew up, well, I grew up from college,
like late teens onwards, watching
people like Steven Crowder, uh,
how the world works. Ellie Dorian, he
doesn't really make videos anymore.
By the time he was one of my favorites,
he did sort of the whole political like
debunking commentary thing. Um, and I,
I still appreciated that because
for so long when I was in college,
I felt like I was in a bubble
and I was the crazy one.
I was the only one with my, of opinions
and everyone else thought the same way.
So in making my videos, I did kind of hope
that maybe for someone else out there,
I could be that lifeline that
was like, hey, you're not crazy.
Someone else also believes this. You're
not losing your mind. You're not a racist.
You're not a sexist just
for thinking differently.
Yeah. What about, um,
just generally what it's like to be
a young person that's a conservative?
It's not the easiest thing. Uh,
and I think in conservatives,
especially right now,
we're so against the idea
of like victim hood culture,
but I don't think it's playing into
victimhood culture to say that it is,
it is difficult.
And you know,
not only am I younger but also
being someone who's half Asian.
And you experienced this because you're
gay and I have watched your Prager, uh,
Prager u show with Kennesaw and it's like
she experiences it because she's black.
But when you are not even conservative
but just not far left and uh,
you know, one of these
protected groups, uh,
that doesn't like fit the mold of who they
think should be disagreeing with them,
you get even more of an attack.
Right? Because then you're called,
I'm called things like an uncle
Chan, um, you know, kind of so on.
This is called really terrible things,
you know.
Well, what is it that they want you to
believe as as a person with some Asian
heritage?
What is it that they want you to believe?
Cause it's a little bit different than
they were. They can say to gay people,
Assay,
we are the ones who got you right.
So you better bow to us forever or black
people, we're giving you this or that.
What does it cause Asians have been by
and large, extremely successful. Yes.
Due to hard work and family
and all those things. Yeah.
So what is it that they want you to be?
They want us to believe that white people
don't accept us. Still see us as other,
uh, I've had, you know,
progressive's tell me that the only
reason that conservatives watch me is
because they think I'm white or that
I'm trying to be white or that they're
tokenizing me and you know, they're
propping me up as a way to say, see,
I'm not racist,
which is really what are the most racist
things that I've ever heard. And that's,
that is hard. And I think we
see like with this, like our,
our oppression hierarchy, um, you know,
they still like to claim
Asians as their own,
but at the same time progressive's right
now we're happy to throw Asians under
the bus when it comes to something
like affirmative action, which it's,
it's been documented actually
harms Asians and it's,
it's really frustrating. Especially I
did a re a video recently on colorism,
which if you're, yeah, it's the
idea that it's not just race,
sorry, wait, okay.
Racism is like prejudice against different
races plus systemic power according
to them.
And then colorism is like,
we're talking more about skin tone so
it can even apply to people within the
same race. Um, so I did a video about
that and you know, frankly, I didn't,
I didn't even disagree with the idea
that colorism exists and that there are
some people out there who might prefer
like a lighter skinned person to a darker
skinned person because I don't think
either of us would say that individual
sexism or racism or whatever
type of prejudice exist, right.
Because people are jerks and
bad people. Yeah, exactly. Be,
um,
but pretty much my video,
I said that I don't think there's enough
evidence to say that colorism affects
something like prison sentencing,
which is what the MTV video that
I was responding to. Sad. And, um,
also that I'm darker skinned black
people get longer prison sentences than
lighter skin black people because of their
race. Right. I'm not just like there,
sorry. Yeah. Yeah. So I'm pretty much,
I was just saying I don't think there's
really evidence to back this up.
And I think the conversations
around colorism,
just like the conversation
surrounding racism,
it's not so much a fight for a quality
anymore as it is to try and bring down
the oppressors or those
more privileged, right. It,
so the conversations surrounding
race I think has evolved too,
unfortunately,
demonize white people in a lot of ways.
And what we're seeing in the conversation
with colorism is that lighter skin
minorities are kind of being
demonized in the same way.
And that that's what my video is about.
Uh,
and I got a lot of people
quite upset that they weren't,
they weren't happy with
that. Uh, you know,
I was told to shut up because my opinion
doesn't matter because I'm not dark
skinned and so I wouldn't know what
it's like to be experienced colorism,
which is nice little bit of irony there
that apparently they didn't get. And I,
yeah, I was just, uh, attacked
for being, you know, uh,
uncle Chan equivalent,
just a puppet used by white people to
try and tear down darker skin minorities.
And it's just, I mean, I've
been watching your stuff.
I don't know if you're feeling like
this a little bit lately, but I'm,
I'm getting really pretty fed up about it,
fed up of being told that I'm not special
enough in terms of diversity points to
have my opinion, man. Yeah. Yeah.
Well, it's funny because I
think you know, this about me,
my general disposition is I'm fairly
agreeable and I try to be respectful and
all those things. But there are
these moments where I'm like,
this thing is so dangerous.
It's so out of control that there are
these moments where I just want to like
unleash hell on these people. Really
like take them down. I'm doing it.
I guess in a, maybe a
more casual, slower. Yeah,
I completely understand.
And it's funny when I started making
my videos I was so under the impression
where it's like, yeah, other people
face controversy and backlash, but I'm,
I'm so variable and like I'm going to
explain it in a way where they can't
misunderstand me,
where it's like obvious that I'm arguing
for more quality and stuff like that.
Clearly not the case.
And I'm still not a provocateur.
My goal is never to upset
people and I really do.
I'm speaking out about these issues
because I want more equality,
but I am at the point now
where it's like, yeah, there,
there are some people who are just
bitter and they're raging ideologues.
They don't want to listen.
They don't care what you say.
They're just going to demonize you based
on who they think you are and use your
identity to, you know, call you a
whole bunch of slurs. It's quite awful.
It is quite awful.
So I know we could,
we could sit here all day long and talk
about what's going on with the left and
how, you know, the, the oppression
Olympics and that whole thing.
Do you see any things on the
right that you're worried about?
Yeah, well I think, you know, politics,
it's almost a game of like back and forth
reaction and then action and then et
Cetera, et cetera. And so on the right,
I'm just worried that there are people
on the right who are getting so fed up
like I am where they're actually seeing
it for the example in the issue of
identity where they're
saying like, yeah, let's,
let's have our own identitarian politics,
which is completely the other way
of where I think we should be going.
And Jordan Peterson speaks out about
this too, where it's like if you,
if you don't like a game
that someone's playing,
you don't respond by playing at
yourself. You Stop, you stop the game.
And I think there are some people on the
right that right now are happy to start
to, you know, buy into it. It's like
maybe, yeah, we have like a black club.
We have a Hispanic club. Why not a
white club where it's like, you know,
you have most reasonable
people. It's like, Whoa, Whoa,
Whoa, let's, let's calm down.
Let's, let's stop this. Um, so that,
that's something I'm worrying about
on on the right. And just in general,
there are people that are so entrenched
in the culture where right now I got
people mad at me.
I lost subscribers because I said that
the captain marvel movie was pretty good.
That's all I said was pretty good.
My brother said he was pretty good too.
I was like,
I was sort of wanting to boycott or
just because of that stupid comment,
but I know it's going to fit right in.
I know.
That's why I want to know
what happens. Uh, yeah.
So I said it was pretty good
and new people freaked out
and I just hope with all
of this stuff that we don't lose sight of.
The reason why we oppose the
authoritarian identity. Marion's, right.
We keep things in perspective.
It's not,
so we can have our own group that does
the same thing to other people. If so,
we can move past this and try to maybe
like calm things down where we can
actually talk about issues and policies
rather than calling everyone else and
not see or like, uh, I dunno,
whatever type of fascist.
So interesting to me because you can
watch videos that I was doing before the
election where I kept saying,
if you guys on the left,
and when I was saying it was,
that's right. I was like,
if we don't stop calling your rotor racist
and stop calling Trump a Nazi and the
rest of it,
we're going to create this on the road.
And it's almost like in a weird way,
that's almost what they want to do,
which makes people like us our job. I
guess that was more important. Right.
And I'm,
the only hope that I have really is that
the loud voices that you hear online
are not representative of
the average person, which I
don't think they are. Right.
You have that vocal minority. And I
think most people who are just, you know,
living their everyday lives,
maybe they have a Twitter account to
follow people they actually know in real
life,
not just like this whole political world
that we're wrapped up and they look at
both of these sides and they just think,
wow, you guys are insane. You're crazy.
Never stops.
Right?
Like every morning there's
another headline about some
gender related thing or
you know, this reverse reverse racism,
just like any old idiotic thing.
And every day I'm like,
Oh, here's another, here's
another. And then it's like,
all right, should we stop fighting
it and just let it be or yeah,
and you have to fight it. I get people
who say that all the time, like,
why are you still out
talking about like x issue?
How about you harped on this enough? And
I mean, on one hand I say like, yeah,
I like,
this is 15 video that I've made about it,
but on the other they're still
doing these things. So I,
I'm personally not even sure what
the best way to combat it anymore is.
Do we ignore it?
Pretend,
pretend it's not happening anymore
to not drive more attention to it,
but would that just kind of be being
complacent and letting them do whatever
they want?
It's a hard balance to strike.
Yeah. So you mentioned the culture
portion of this before. Yeah.
Tagline for your show is,
it's like your culture,
the intersection of culture
and politics, politics. Um,
I find that I'm not that
interested in politics anymore.
That the culture thing has become much
more interesting to me because the
politics thing is after.
Yeah. Well everyone says it's
downstream, right? That was,
I guess Breitbart's line. It's the
politics of masters from culture. Um,
but everything has become this,
right? Yeah. And it's, it's
funny because, um, you know,
I will have people who will ask me,
what do you think about this bill or this
policy? Why don't you talk more about,
um, something like foreign
aid? And you know, my,
my background is in political science.
I was a researcher for my
professors when I was in school,
so I am really interested in policy.
Uh, it's not that I'm not, but I,
I think that right now what's happening
happening culturally, this is,
we can't even begin to talk about what,
for example,
presidential candidates think about that.
I don't know,
domestic spending when everyone's being
called a racist or a sexual Predator or
you know, it, it's just,
it's hard to get too political talking
points when you first have to debunk that
you're a white supremacist.
Right.
And I really want to get to the point
where we can talk about those issues,
but right now we have this huge block in
front of us and I think especially when
we're talking about younger voters,
which are becoming a bigger and
bigger influence in elections,
so much of what younger voters,
you know,
what they choose to support is based
on things like cultural aspects.
So I don't think we can ignore that.
[inaudible] do you get a lot of emails
or tweets from sort of young lefties?
Cause I think every,
by default most people are lefties.
It's just when they're young.
Yeah, it's media and it's uh,
it's Hollywood.
It's the whole thing.
Sort of the default position
is your left and right.
I'm sure you're getting some 16,
17,
18 year olds that are watching your
videos and going, Whoa, maybe I'm not
okay. Yeah, well I'm actually
a pretty good it does.
And at any time because you probably
get the burnout too sometimes where it's
like, oh gosh, I've said something
and now people are [inaudible]. Um,
it is really encouraging to get someone
who says, Hey, I love your videos.
I used to be really this way,
but you've kind of opened my mind to
things and I don't think identify the same
way that I used to or even, and maybe
not even that, but just someone who says,
Hey, I'm, I'm a liberal, I'm on the left.
But I still enjoy watching your
videos for a different perspective.
And that to me is what's so encouraging
and why I keep making videos.
Yeah. Yeah. So what are some of the
issues that are on your mind right now?
So I've seen you do a lot
about the gender stuff, Austin,
where are you at with the whole
transgender movement at the moment?
Well, it's, it's funny because, uh, as
far as I know, I am no way a transpo.
I would never treat someone differently
or withhold human rights from them based
on how, on how they identify
or anything like that.
That's really clear about this.
So when they click this video,
so you don't have an irrational
fear of trans? No, no, no. I don't.
To be bigoted towards them. Were
prejudicial towards, no, no I don't. Um,
but I think the whole conversation
around gender right now,
it's coming to a point where we're
not just saying, hey, you know,
these are people with, uh, you know, this,
this medical condition
which had been diagnosed.
Like let's try to support them in whatever
way doctors think our best, you know,
let's make sure they don't feel
alienated. It's gone from that to, um,
not only is gender not a real thing, but
biological sex is also not a real thing.
And also lets a,
it's okay to give hormones to kids.
So the conversation has really,
really derailed from where it was,
I think even just five years
ago, which is, is scary to me.
And we do a lot of videos on the show,
pseudo intellectual about how the
stuff is affecting young kids.
Because I think a lot of people,
they may watch a video that I've done
about transgender issues or whatever,
and think, why do you care? Why
does it matter to you? Like this?
Stop butting into other people's lives.
And you know,
I on a person to person level,
like, I don't care what you do,
your body or however you
prefer to your life, go for it.
But this matters because of
systemic issues, right? It's, it's,
it's gotten a lot bigger than that.
We have, um, laws like in Canada,
they'll see 16 that may criminalize
speech if you don't use someone's correct
pronoun.
Um,
we actually have cases now where parents
are having to go to court because they
don't want their children
to be given hormones. Um,
so this isn't just,
this isn't just affecting individuals.
And this isn't just me being a jerk and
not wanting to use this pronoun for you.
Um, you know, I'm talking about this
issue because it's affecting I think,
individual freedoms and parental rights
and mainly parental rights because we
see this coming down
into the school systems.
So for someone that is
paying attention to this,
that's doing a lot of videos on
these topics for that very reason,
are you shocked how much trans
stuff is the only way I can put it?
Yeah. He's just constantly out there.
Like it seems so disproportionately
focused on it is absolutely
disproportionately what
you're saying. Yeah, no, it is
completely disproportionate.
And uh, you know, we did a video about
rapid onset gender dysphoria, um,
because a lot of us kind of
just observing might think, wow,
it seems like there are a lot more
trans identifying people than before.
Maybe we're crazy. No, actually that's
correct. Numbers have really skyrocketed,
especially among young, younger
generations. Um, so they,
they've begun to do studies and they
found that gender dysphoria actually
manifests itself, especially among
young girls in social clusters.
Right.
If there's a teenage or maybe
early twenties girl who's
now identifying as maybe
not a girl,
she believes she's trans,
it's actually quite likely that in her
social group there is another person
that's doing as well.
So this study I was actually looking
at whether it's possible that gender
dysphoria could be somewhat of a social
contagion there. Their phrase not mine.
Um, similar to things like bulemia
anorexia and things like that.
And they actually did found that yet
there's a strong correlation. Um,
what that means is that the
people who are saying, hey,
maybe we shouldn't be teaching this at
such young age or maybe we shouldn't be,
um,
you know,
glamorizing it as this like new
trend because it might affect people.
Maybe we are right. Maybe we're not just
being crazy and bigoted and again, why,
what's the big deal?
So they identify as a different person.
A lot of people might be
asking, um, well, you know,
becoming whatever you want
when it involves things like
hormones and potentially
surgeries, it, this is a big deal. This
isn't something we should be minimizing.
Yeah. Have you found it's hard to find
people on the left to talk to these issues
about
yes, yes. It's, it's very hard and the
response that I've been met with is that,
you know, you hate me, you're denying
my humanity, uh, you want to erase me,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
It's frustrating because that's no matter
what someone may call themselves at
the end of the day,
they're another person and I,
I would never wish them harm or
want them to be deprived of life,
liberty or property or anything like that.
And I would like to think I would also
want to be kind to them too. So it's,
it is, it is hurtful. I like having
all those doors close in your face.
Yeah. Are you as a sort of hopeful,
would I, for what I would call it,
sort of the new center,
right?
That I think is sort of
conservatives like yourself.
Like there's just a younger breed of
conservatives that I think are a little
more tolerant on some of the social
stuff than the libertarian saved.
A classical liberal is the x lefties
that there really is something growing
right now. They're, for all the
reasons that everything feels crazy,
it's actually something really
nice taking root right now.
If you could just sort of step away
from the craziness for a minute.
Yeah, I think so. Um, you know,
it's very encouraging to see how youtube
as a platform has kind of played its
own role in furthering political
and cultural conversations
among younger people.
Wait, so it's not making everyone part of
the, Oh, no, no. Were you on that thing,
by the way?
I was on that thing,
that alternative and alternative
influence networks, which have no,
this is from data and society.
I mean everyone watching
this thing, but you know,
there was no scientific basis for
that study. All they did, I've been,
I'm sure you know. Yeah. We'll just
draw pictures to all of our names.
So you've been on my show. I've been on
Rogan show Rogan, talk to Sam Harris.
They drew all this picture and then the,
the study basically said we're,
we're turning people on
the far right. Yeah. Uh,
but there's been subsequent actual
studies where people have shown that we've
actually d radicalized a lot of
people in ways. So just bananas. Yeah.
And actually a temple. I know. I was
honored to be on the chart with you.
Thank you. I appreciate it. Yeah, I'm Tim
Pool for, I know you've spoken to about,
he was like,
yeah,
my connections weren't even real.
I didn't even appear on shows
with these people. And you know,
I didn't even bother to check my
little connections. What are they like,
they're not gonna care
if I was or if I wasn't.
I know that I'm not radicalizing
people, so it's like, Eh, whatever.
Um,
what are you worried that when things
like that come out and
then they put you on that,
that then we see the way these things
get escalated where then it's like, oh,
Lauren talked to this person who's in
a accused white supremacists and now
Facebook says you can't be a white
supremacist and be on Facebook,
but now you're that much closer to them.
Yeah.
And Ruben talked to this one
and Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah.
So I know you've talked about, you spoke
about social media censorship before,
which I appreciate because I feel like
more people need to be talking about this
and the reaction that I get from some
people is that like you're paranoid.
Like you're just, you know, you're
seeing a boogeyman where there's not,
if people aren't watching your videos,
because I don't want to watch it.
Like people maybe just don't care to
engage with your tweets, whatever. Um,
you do get called paranoid when
you talk about these things,
but then you have these lists,
right?
There's a list literally linking you to
actual white supremacists and then you
know, someone like youtube comes out
and say, they outright say, yeah,
we are going to be, I'm not recommending
extremist or conspiracy content.
And you're kind of like, well, I'm on
that list. Does that mean I'm mixed?
Like I don't think this is just
paranoia. Yeah. To worry about this. Um,
and you know, part of me, like I said,
they're going to say what they're going
to say. The other part of me is like,
wait, this does matter because
this affects who can see my videos,
my ability to get my message
out there and never mind that.
I don't want someone who doesn't know who,
who I am,
whatever being told that I'm a Nazi so
they shouldn't watch my videos and just
write me off entirely.
That's not a good, yeah.
Right. And you could also brush a lot
of it off your shoulder, but you know,
we're still people too. And it's like
when you go to get a slice of pizza,
if there's someone standing there that's
looking at you and they heard that
you're a white supremacist,
that's, that's no fun.
No, no, for sure.
And I think people who fling
these words at people online,
and I don't know if they
really believe it, if they,
if they're actually people out there
who believe that I am a Nazi and a white
supremacist or if they're just trying to
be, you know, hurtful and inflammatory,
but I don't think they realize how much
damage that does. Like not just to a,
you know, a platform or a career.
But just like personally, like you,
you kind of have to defend to people who
maybe know you in real life. Like, hey,
why people saying that about you?
Because again,
for people who aren't in
our crazy online world,
maybe they don't know that Nazi is just
another word for disagrees with you.
Right. Because I mean, if you told me
10 years ago that so and so was a Nazi,
I'll probably been like,
oh my gosh. Oh, now it's the
boy who cried wolf. Yeah.
And now every time they say that
about somebody or one of those things,
I start having to really,
I'd now,
even lately I've been thinking about some
of the people over the years that were
really called this or
that, and I'm like, man,
did I really not understand
what the actual truth was?
And the answer probably is yes.
Yeah.
And that's,
that's a scary place to be in if when
we're kids have lost their meaning,
because I mean,
I'm sure you feel the same way.
I actually do think being a Nazi as a bad
thing, like being a racist or a record.
Yeah. Like full disclosure, not
pro Nazi-ism, not pro sexism,
not I'm, I'm pro good things,
anti bad things. Uh, so like it,
it's hard when people kind of just muddy
the waters and it's like words don't
mean anything anymore.
And you were called the worst
things imaginable on a daily basis.
Yeah. So how has been working for,
uh, for Glen over at the blaze?
Cause that's,
that's all part of this conversation.
It's like here's a guy who was I think
unfairly demonized for a long time and
who has also said that,
you know,
he was part of the sort of cable news
problem in the outreach thing. Yeah.
But he's kind of head is mia culpa about
it and he's trying to build bridges now
and it's like I give that guy a lot
of credit. No, no one's perfect.
And we've all done things in our
past that we're not proud of.
Yeah, for sure. And I mean,
the thing with blaze TV,
what I love about them is that they
give us so much freedom and just control
over our product. So you know,
anything you see on our show,
which all the videos are up on
youtube now, which is another thing,
I'm happy for them there.
They've given us the freedom to just give
our content to the general public. Um,
is that we from start to finish
control what we want to say.
I have never been fed a line. Okay,
you have to take this position on,
on this topic and you can't say this,
don't like don't talk to this person.
I've not been told that. Where, I mean,
and if you're familiar with
how like bigger networks
operate, that's really rare.
That doesn't happen all the time.
And I don't think people understand that.
And I still get people all the time who
come to me. I'll be tagged like, hey,
like this person who's also on
[inaudible] said this and this.
How could you work with
someone that blah, blah, blah.
Or did you see what x person said is
like, I don't know what they say. Like,
and they can say whatever they want.
I'm going to say what I say.
And I think there are some people who are
so into purity testing that they can't
even imagine a network or a, you know,
a platform where that doesn't happen.
We're not, everybody needs to tow
the same line about the same issue.
And I think that like
it boggles their minds.
Yeah.
Do you hold any positions that are sort
of outside of what general conservatives
or cause I think of you a little
bit more as a libertarian generally.
I, I actually did go through my
libertarian phase in college. Um,
I used to call myself
a conservatory and um,
but now like with issues like the,
the border,
which I know is kind of even among
libertarians themselves are not really
together on. So like I, I generally just
call myself a conservative right now.
I don't know if there are issues.
Oh, I got one. The environment. Um,
I think there are definitely people
on the right who don't believe climate
change exists at all. I am
not one of those people. Um,
and then,
you know,
going even further that there are some
people on the right who do you believe
that climate change is an issue but they
don't think that government should be
involved? Um, I wouldn't be against, um,
I don't know.
I'm trying to think of like a green
initiative that I would support,
but just in general, I am sort of public
private combination. Yeah, exactly.
Because I don't want the green new deal.
That would be one of the worst
things that could happen just for,
for many reasons.
I think
that a freshman senator
never done anything
other than win reelection could write
a document that would reorganize the
entire economy is introduce
ubi as like a footnote now.
And you don't have to work in cow farts.
Yeah. You don't think that's a good idea.
Um,
but yeah,
that is what I would say that I'm more
environmentally conscious than maybe
other people on the right. Um,
what else? Also a, the issue,
I don't know if people on the
right are against prison reform.
I don't think they're against it, but I
think we don't talk about it enough. Um,
so I, I think maybe I put more importance
on that than other people along on the
right. Do we make this a Trump
guy ever do this again? Yeah,
I think I, I think I saw him on a tweet
or something. You can, um, the tweeter.
Yeah.
So I'm one of those people
who never thought that Trump
would win and I was like
unimaginable to me. Um,
but now that he has,
I think he's done a lot of good for
conservative values and I am someone who
will never defend what comes out of his
mouth in terms of what he said about
Rosie O'donnell or, uh, who was that? Who
is Horseface again? Which one was that?
Someone was worse face. Stormy
Daniels. Yeah. It's like,
I'm not on board with that,
but in terms of,
I guess what his administration
has implemented, I mean,
right now in terms of the economy,
black people, Hispanic people,
women, their unemployment
rates are at record lows.
I think that's something that everybody,
regardless of how you feel about Donald
Trump as a person should be happy for.
Yeah.
For some reason the
congressional Democrats couldn't
applaud that at the state
of the weird, yeah, that
was, that was strange.
It's like I thought you were for that.
And you know,
never mind like black entrepreneurship
is also at an all time high.
And something that frustrates me is that
I get called like anti black a lot and
it's like, well, policies that
I support have led to this,
led to these people having jobs,
being able to start their own businesses.
Like that to me is the most pro
black you could possibly be.
Empowering these people to,
you know,
take control of their own lives and be
able to be successful based on their own
merit, which they absolutely have.
Have you figured out any tricks to,
to win over those young
people who are on the fence?
Like just the story that you can
tell or just a tactic that you have?
I think overall just being willing to
really understand what your proponent is
saying does go a long
way with some people. Um,
because I've had people comment that
I'm glad you don't try to oversimplify
things or you know,
shy away from issues that maybe don't
make your side look good. Um, and again,
like I'll,
I'll bring about the environment.
I'm not saying that I absolutely do
not believe that the government, uh,
should be just putting all the money
into solar and wind in the hopes that
something happens. Um, but
I'm, I going to deny that.
I think we should be talking about the
issue of the environment. No, I'm not.
And I think just being able to have
that goes a long way for some people.
And then, I mean, of
course there are these,
these ideologues who you're never
going to connect with and I,
that's something that I've had to come
to terms with that some people just don't
want to listen and there's nothing you
can say that was going to change their
mind. But for a lot of people, I think
they understand when someone's being,
or at least trying to be
rational and reasonable.
Yeah.
So,
even though you've bounced around the
world and you've done your roaming thing,
you're,
you're based in Canada now.
Is it weird to you sometimes to think
how much of what you think about and talk
about and focus on is actually
all coming from another country?
Well,
it's funny,
I have people all the time we say like
why you always talking about American
politics? I don't really talk
about politics that much.
I'm kind of like you go to the culture.
Yeah.
I goes to the culture and I had someone,
I made a comment about the Hashtag my
white privilege thing that was going
around and I was told to stay
out of American politics in my,
my sponsor was like, how is
this American politics? Um,
cause these cultural issues,
they don't end at borders because the
internet doesn't end up borders, right?
This online presence
doesn't end at borders.
So especially when I'm talking
about issues like a gender
or race, where we have,
are extremely liberal government
that's actually putting these kinds of
ideologies into law.
I think I'm absolutely talking about
something that applies to my country.
And I think it's something that,
it's funny like maybe some of these
Americans who are on the left,
they're trying to tell me to butt out. Um,
if I were perhaps, I mean this is like,
it's all, all conversation, but if I
were perhaps an undocumented immigrant,
they maybe were, it wouldn't be so, uh,
like anti foreign. Um, but also I just,
I think that some people need
to recognize that culture is,
it doesn't stop at borders.
And so like these issues affect Canadians.
These issues affect Brits and my,
my breakdown of who watches my show,
it's like about 60% Americans. Um, but
then I had like a good 10% Canadians,
10% of Brits, and you know, the rest
of the angles sphere, the Australian.
So these really are global issues.
So basically you're in
California right now.
If we could get you to overstay
your visa or something. Not Easy.
You're just busy visiting.
Yeah.
We just get you to cancel your
return flight and then just,
you just hide out here.
We'll make you an illegal immigrant.
And then you could argue as an illegal
and then maybe they will listen to me.
You'll see how quickly they turn against.
Exactly. Yeah. Yeah. That will be,
I have thought about that before, but
now I'm just, I'm just kidding. Yeah.
That will, that will not go over well.
Yeah. Um, what are some of the other, oh,
so you mentioned that my white
privilege Hashtag that was going around.
So for people that have no idea for the
people that are saying enough not to be
on Twitter,
why those people by white privilege,
this Hashtag that was started on
Twitter and it ended up trending. Um,
and it was metaphor,
just white people to check their privilege
to mention instances or maybe trends
they've noticed that are
due to their whiteness,
a privilege that they know that a
non white person would not get. Yeah.
And the thing is like,
I don't deny the idea of privilege exists.
Like I coming from a two parent household,
I've lived a lot of places.
I've gone to good schools.
I absolutely acknowledge that I've had
privileges that a lot of people haven't
had. You know, that's,
is that privilege or is that just life
experience? You've had a life experience.
They're
kind of, they're kind interchangeable.
Like I don't have systemic privilege,
but I've had,
you know,
things that afforded to me in my life
that other people haven't had and life's
not fair and I don't think anyone
would dispute that life isn't fair. Um,
and that's that. But I think, you know,
the idea when other people
mentioned white privilege,
they're talking about the idea that
for white people, um, you know,
their skin color affords them certain
privileges that non white people don't
have. Um, and I think that's a very,
very toxic mentality. And if you,
I was reading some of those tweets and
just like blood pressure just raising
through the roof as painful to read some
of them. It really is self flagellation.
Yeah. Oh my gosh. It's like the,
you can kind of like almost imagine these
like white progressive's like on their
knees trying to grovel down before
they're non white friends and like,
apologize for the whiteness
of their skin. It's, it's,
it's depressing and embarrassing to watch,
I think. And you know, they talk about,
they like I got pulled over by a cop and
then he didn't give me a ticket Hashtag
my white privilege. And it's like, well, I
mean sometimes cops, like I personally, I,
I've never been pulled
over and knock on a ticket.
I've only gotten a ticket ones, but it's
like I've never been given that kind of,
you know, leeway a, you know,
I've had teachers maybe who were
a little more lenient for me.
Is that because I'm white or is it because
of my female or was it because I'm a
good student?
There's where we are so keen to attribute
motive to people and like it just
reinforces this idea that yeah,
white people are privileged and it's
annoying because now merely denying the
existence of white privilege
makes you a racist and a bigot.
Do you think it's fair to say that
these people are the new racist?
Like if I was to really pick like,
I don't like doing this because you
said something before you don't want to
become yeah.
While you're fighting against.
So I don't want to start walking
around and, and labeling these people,
read racists and all of the things that
they have no problem labeling the rest
of us. But if you were to ask me where
does racism come from in America today,
it is coming from the left. If were
to sexism come from in America today,
all CIS gendered White Christian men or
this or white people are this, these are,
these are leftist ideas that aren't
just like ephemeral things happening on
Twitter.
These are things that they're,
that the lefty politicians are talking
about, the presidential candidates for,
the Democrats are talking about. Yeah.
So that's why it's so dangerous to me.
Yeah. And I agree with
that. And I wouldn't know.
I have friends who are on the
left and progressive, um, who are,
who I do think at the end
of the day want to quality.
I think we have different ideas about
how to get there. Um, so, you know,
I wouldn't just base on someone being
a progressive, call them racist.
But I think if you,
if you are someone who thinks that
because of the color of their skin,
someone is not entitled to have an opinion
about a certain issue that is racist.
If you, if you are someone
who thinks that you know,
this person because of their skin color
is entitled to either more or less of a,
of a starting point or a advantage or
disadvantage, then you are a racist.
And I think historically generally kind
of been the agreed upon definition of
racist. So yeah, like there's
no reverse racism. It's just
racism. Yes. Racism. I was talking
to somebody of a progressive, uh,
who's a family friend and we
were getting into it and I said,
are you for affirmative
action that she said, yes,
we have to help minorities
get more jobs on that. I said,
are you for discriminating
against white people? And she
said, no. And I said, well,
how do you do? How do you negotiate?
How do you reconcile those two things?
And I said, well, what about your
kids? You, she has three kids. I said,
well what about your kids? Do you
think your kids happened to be white?
Do you think that everything being equal,
if they're going up against the minority,
they should not get the job.
And she was like,
well no,
because then you have to take it on
a case by case basis. And I said,
well you just made different
first argument but they
can't quite get over that
sort of disconnect. And that's what
I think we have to keep doing to,
to get them there,
to make them realize. I think,
I think you're absolutely right.
And I think for a lot of progressives
they do think that they're doing the right
thing. Almost, maybe even a little
bit of a white savior complex.
I would say they need to come
in and rescue them. But, um,
when it comes to like
affirmative action specifically,
it frustrates me that so many people on
the left are keen to conflate class with
race. Um, you know, cause they'll
say like, oh well, you know,
for black kids they don't have the
same resources growing up in schools.
And it's like, well, hang
on. I went to good schools,
we had some black kids
that were definitely richer
than my family or you know,
like vice versa and it's like sellout.
Yeah.
It's like if you want to
have a conversation about
class in school funding,
then let's have that.
Which I actually, you know,
I think one of the privileges that is
kind of undeniable is that some kids are
afforded more luxuries in their schools
or whatever than other kids, you know,
in an inner city kid is not going to
have the same education or whatever.
So let's try to address that and say how
we can improve the inner city schools
and stuff. That's where you'd have
the conversation. Yeah, exactly. Yeah.
Mentoree school in Beverly Hills.
Guess what?
It's way more funded
than the average school.
The teachers have different
classifications. So how do
you deal with that? Okay,
yeah. Then that's a good starting spot.
But unfortunately that's not this. No,
because then they want to
make it all about race.
And it's like that distinction matters
because how we see the problem affects
how we assault, how we
solve the problem. Um,
so it's like you and I can't just kind of
go to them and it's like, Hey, here are,
you know, proposals for like,
uh, budgets or you know,
how to deal with teacher's unions,
whatever.
For the schools when they see
the problem as systemic racism,
like you're not gonna get anywhere
with people like that. And it's,
it's frustrating because like
that whole narrative and I,
I get flack, I get accused of like, oh,
you don't really care about, you know,
the black community or whatever.
You're just kind of like, you're,
you just like to say whatever racist
stuff you want. And it's like, no,
I am trying to [inaudible] I make videos
trying to talk about, you know, the,
the importance of fathers and families,
you know,
how important it is to have economic
freedoms that really allow people to
succeed.
It's like,
that actually is what I think would be
most useful to vulnerable communities of
whatever color. There's a ton of evidence
that supports that. Yes. Yeah, yeah.
But it's like they don't,
because it doesn't feed into the
narrative of systemic racism.
They don't even want to hear it. And they,
they accuse you of not wanting to help.
How much of this
do you think is just for
young people especially? Um,
it's just the excesses
of the West that we have.
Things have gone so well for us now
for so long. If you live in America,
you're basically free. You are free,
you may have problems, but you are free.
You live in the freest society ever.
And that young people now who can play
fort night all day long or watch porn or
whatever the hell else there is to
do or play video games or whatever,
it's like they now have to
find problems with everything.
And what's the easiest thing to
do once you find the problem?
It's just to burn the whole system down,
not to actually acknowledge that, Whoa,
this took a lot of blood, sweat,
and tears of generations before you.
Yeah.
That's such a good point.
And not only are people free in the u s
they are economically prosperous by any
metric.
You take someone who's living in poverty
in the United States and you compare it
to a global level is still doing
pretty dang well. You know,
someone who grew up in Southeast Asia,
you know,
Hong Kong and Singapore are
very prosperous countries,
but I visited to places like Indonesia
and Thailand where they're like,
that actually is structural
poverty. So, you know,
I'm able to recognize how privileged
we are just to be in the west. Um,
and I think a lot of millennials now,
they been painted a picture
where capitalism has failed,
the American dream is dead.
AOC says that all the time.
Like we're living in of like, you know,
all the billionaires have all the money,
the working class, we're screwed. We
don't have anything that's not true.
And that's not to say that issues like
high tuition don't exist and stuff. Yeah,
absolutely they do.
We should talk about it.
But overall we are living in such
tremendous affluence and prosperity and
equality that the fact that there
are people, you know, saying, no,
this is so broken, we need to start
all over and tear it all down.
It like freaks me out.
Can you move to New York,
run against AOC and what do I,
what do I have to do to him?
I don't think the fund has some
campaign finance. What are we talking?
It would take a lot of campaign finance
to get me to New York. I tell you that.
Not my favorite city,
but I mean I think even
people are starting to wake
up to the fact like we had
the whole Amazon Toboco right? Um,
and at the end of the day, like, yeah,
people love the sort of like socialist,
populous rhetoric,
but you know what else they love is
just actual jobs. And so when, you know,
when we had Amazon being chased away,
we did have like,
angry New Yorkers being like,
okay, but wait, 25,000 jobs. Yeah.
Like I, everyone loves Amazon.
It's actually gets there fast.
Even if you don't work for Amazon,
you get to be part of like the growing
economy surrounding and providing support
to that, to that business. Uh, I think
people are, at the end of the day,
what they want more than
anything else is jobs. And like,
not necessarily the promise that I don't
think is even possible to provide of
like, oh, just all the, all
this free stuff. At least
that's what I'm hoping for a,
but it is, it is really, I don't
know, depressing, frustrating,
sad,
whatever negative.
Where do you want to use a to
see a generation of millennials,
socialists or communists, whatever. Um,
completely misrepresent the environment
that we are living in now and not
recognize how lucky they are.
Yeah,
we got to wake these people up,
but I guess I guess you're
doing a pretty good job.
Well, I, you know,
I've read people suggest we should have
some sort of like internships study
abroad program where we just send people,
you know,
these progressive mainly white,
rich millennials to places like
Venezuela or just like, you know,
foreign places where they can maybe see
a little bit more of the outside world
beyond their bubbles or what
they've been fed to really,
really see how the u s stands or the West
in general compared to other countries.
W what do you make of
the free college thing?
I suspect you're not for
free college generally,
but what about just college
as an institution because
of the brainwashing that's
going on or you even for young
people going to college at this?
I have so many feet cause you know,
I'm someone who I really,
I worked my butt off when I was in
high school to kind of get to the best
college that I could. Um, I, I
took it really, really seriously.
When I was in college. I worked
for my professors. Uh, you know,
all my friends were in academia.
Uh,
it was kind of like assumed because I
was in that world that I would go on and
have my master's and stuff. And I have
a lot of respect for academia. Um,
but at the state, and I would
never say that college is useless,
but at the same time,
I think we're reaching
a point now where a,
so, so much of what colleges do
now is not really instruction,
but it's indoctrination and be
the return on a college degree.
Especially if you're taking something
like a gender studies or feminist theories
degree or whatever it may be.
The, the return is not worth it.
Can I get a job with
lesbian badminton degree?
I mean,
as buzzfeed hiring,
that's essentially the only place that
I would know what it would look at it.
But I think we,
we need to kind of reevaluate how
we see college because you know,
other countries they have really,
they have things like a trade schools
and things like that where, you know,
it's not anti-education cause I'm not
anti-education I'm always pro education.
More knowledge is always good, but college
is not the only way to get education.
And I think colleges, if you look
at where they're spending money on,
they've really inflated the number
of administrators they have.
You have entire diversity boards
and things now. It's like,
where did you come from? Who's paying
your salary while the students are,
and I don't think it's
worth it. I, you know,
president Trump is actually taking
measures now to try and enforce freedom of
speech on canvases, which I
think is really important. Um,
but I am against the idea that
everybody needs to go to college.
The only way to be successful is
to go to college. And I think by,
by doing now we've kind of like,
we've made the leftist in academia and
touchable because they have like wave
after wave of student who's,
you know,
willing to pay to get in so
they can be indoctrinated.
What is it that sort of the brilliance
of it when you hear burns, sorry,
Burns like, okay, free college
for everybody. So what can we do?
We're going to send them for free,
which obviously is not free.
There'll be indoctrinated into these ideas
even further and then what does he do
when you get out? Well now you're
going to be guaranteed a federal job.
Yeah,
that sounds horrible.
Can you imagine anything that sounds
worse now and it's like you can never get
out and you're going to be some pencil
pusher doing nothing. That's not for you.
A cog in the system essentially.
And what I think,
I really haven't seen many people who
are suggesting free tuition I talk about
is okay, if it's all government
subsidized, fine, but like
how do we lower costs?
Because it shouldn't just be about who
pays it, but how much they're paying.
And you know,
costs in the United States have risen
so much faster than inflation when it
comes to college. And there are a lot
of different factors. I, you know,
like the student loans,
the way that you can't get rid of a
student loan debt with bankruptcy.
There's a whole bunch of things,
but I don't see enough people talking
about how to lower those costs back down
to what, what they used to be. Because
I mean, you have people who, if you,
if you go to some, somewhere like USC, uh,
it's going to be like, what, 60 k a year.
So that's like 240,000 by the
time you're done. And it's like,
it's ridiculous and it shouldn't,
it shouldn't cost that.
I don't think I made $240,000 in all of
my twenties if I took all of the money.
Yeah, I'm sure I did all those
years of struggling comedy at,
it's like that's what you're
paying to go to college.
It, nevermind the interest on that,
right? Yeah. So no, it's a like, you know,
I on the right and kind of like syndromes,
we make fun of those people with $240,000
of worth of debt for their useless
arts degree. Um, but I mean
are they, I do think like,
I'm not going to deny that there's
a problem with college costs,
it's just that I don't think the answer
is okay. So just full on socialism.
Government pays everything for it.
I think we need to have a conversation
about how to lower those costs again.
And uh,
I think right now students are paying
for a lot of diversity and administrative
faculty. They're paying for
a lot of research done by
their professors, which is,
I mean, kind of great because American
universities are really at the forefront
worldwide of any type of research,
but at the same time,
it's like at what cost it's
costing the American students.
And I think community college is
a great alternative. Uh, you know,
cause obviously it's, it's a lot
more affordable and heck, if you,
if you still want that, that, you
know, whatever name brand, university,
Harvard or the Yale or whatever,
you can always transfer after
you get your associates.
Yeah. All right. A couple more for
you. Sure. Let me ask you some,
I'll turn identity politics
on you. Uh, which would be,
why aren't there more women in this space?
You're one of the few alleys, Stuckey.
There's a couple, um, book, but I
wish there were more women, not,
not for identity politics purposes,
partly just a little bit
for the optics of it.
So that when we're all getting
attacked for all this stuff, it's like,
here's this, here's the low resolution
part of this. Here's more women. Yeah.
Even though it has nothing to do
with your ideas and everything else,
which is really what matters of course.
I think the reason why there aren't more
women in this fear is kind of why there
aren't more women in politics in general,
is that this is a very aggressive
sphere. It really is. And I think for,
for me even it's, it can be overwhelming
for a lot of people who, you know,
aren't you,
you put your ideas out there and then
you're going to just get attacked like
ruthlessly. So, and I'm not saying that
men don't as well, but I think maybe,
uh, as, as a, as a female identifying
person, whatever the PC, you know,
it for a, for a lot of women it might be
a little bit harder to just say, okay,
like, let me brush that off,
move on and forget about it.
And especially if you are a woman who's
speaking out against progressive ideas,
you're going to get even more attention
than maybe a white male that's doing so.
Because I think a lot of
people figure, oh, oh,
another white guy who hates feminism,
who cares? But if you're a woman,
then it's like you're,
you're going against the grain.
It's like error in the system and they
really feel the need to double down.
I mean, regardless of what you
think about the Trump family,
the way that Melania and
Ivanka Trump are treated,
I think most of us would agree
is completely vile, sexist,
the things that they are,
they are called and it's a unfortunately
kind of par for the course for
conservative women or you know,
someone who is gay and speaking
out against the left or black,
you get that much more pushback.
So I think that alone unfortunately
is enough for a lot of people to say,
I don't know about this.
I don't know if it's for me.
So are you hopeful for the future?
Ooh,
um, uh, you know what? I think my,
my answer kind of goes back and forth
for that. There are some days, you know,
um, when, for example,
I see people speaking out against
maybe the Gillette ad and not,
not being like totally irrational and,
you know,
wanting to burn cars
down over a commercial.
Cause that's all it is at the end of
the day. But kind of saying like, okay,
this is stupid. You don't need to do
this to sell razor blades. Uh, you know,
it stays like that where I think,
okay good.
Most people have kind of wanted to leave
all of this identity politics in the,
in the trash. Great. And then
there are other days like I,
I knew during the Cavenaugh
hearing where I'm like, okay,
nevermind just this was a
mistake. Asteroid, just, we're
ready, we're ready. So I,
I go back and forth, but I think you've
looking at Gen z, they're one of the
generations most ready to like reject
this whole like far left thing and that
we've seen in a while. So I don't know
about how hopeful I am from millennials,
but I think maybe the,
the next generation a little bit more.
Yeah, that's actually exactly
where I was going to end this.
Then suddenly there's this now bursts
of younger people. You're going to be,
you're going to be old to these people.
I hate to tell you,
but that are now coming out and going,
Whoa,
we've seen the last five years of abject
hysteria or lunacy and now they are
becoming more conservative.
And maybe that is the
silver lining out of all.
Yeah. Well, cause I think and people make
fun of this mean, but it's kind of true.
Or it's like conservatism is
almost counterculture right now.
And a lot of people on the left laugh
about that. But I mean, think about it.
If you are a young person who's in school
right now, like all of your teachers,
you know, all of the media
that you watch, the, the,
the school books you're being
given to that are given to you,
they all push this progressive agenda.
So what do you do if you want to rebel
against that? Because let's face it,
young people,
if there's like tales all this time
is that young people like to rebel.
We like to be different.
We like to like,
I'm doing my own thing and we've
all been teenagers. Yeah. Um,
so how does a young person
do that right now? Well,
it's not by kind of committing yourself
to PC life and culture. That's not,
that's not edgy. That's not against
the grain. It's by saying no. Like,
I'm gonna listen to this offensive
comedian. I'm going to listen to like,
you know, one of the, the people who I,
I hear my professors or my
parents or whatever telling
me not to watch, you know,
like the Jordan Peterson is the Dave
Rubin's the real scandalous spicy one.
Yeah. Um, and you know,
I don't want conservatism to just become
something people do to or believe in to
get back at other people,
but I'm hoping, you know,
if maybe there's that little
bit of like tantalizing, um,
forced to get them there.
Then once they start watching the videos,
they'll see that, oh, this
does make the most sense.
So I'm not only doing this to get back
at my teachers or my parents or whatever,
but this actually does
seem like an ideology,
a belief system that can help people
succeed by themselves and can promote a
quality.
Yeah.
Well,
I just want to say that I think what
you're doing is awesome and the fact that
you've grown so much in the two and a
half years since we did that little thank
you two week thing. I mean, you're, you're
becoming a star in this space and it's,
it's great. We need people like
you, and as homer Simpson said,
you're a person like you.
Right?
I am a person like me. I thank you. And,
and you're just back at you
watching you and Dr. Peterson go on,
go on your tour and everything.
It's,
it's great because it's almost like
this is becoming mainstream, right?
It's not some like little internet
niche to disagree with these people.
Like there are real people and all of
these cities who are attracted to these,
these ideas in this movement,
and it's really encouraging.
All right, let's keep going
then. Yeah. For more on. Lauren,
follow her on Twitter at the Laura Chen.
[inaudible].